One Design Team out of five will be
chosen for the permanent one October
Memorial here in Las Vegas committee
members looked at those plans today
Brian will shows us their ideas right
here on the corner of Reno drive and Las
Vegas Boulevard is where the one October
committee is planning to create a
memorial to honor the many lives lost
and pay tribute to the victims survivors
and heroes of that tragic day
I thank you in advance for the work you
will do
and I ask that during your journey you
take the time to get to know the 58 you
seek to honor on Wednesday the final
five design teams presented their ideas
for a permanent Memorial to the one
October committee this is Derek Sola
with jcj architecture our goal is to
create a piece in the midst of pain
we call this infinite memory
it is the Everlasting memory of those
who so senselessly perish that day the
teams include professional designers and
even a Nevada licensed architect
Christopher Torres hopes for more public
input we want to make sure that all
voices are heard and represented and
that our most current priorities are
reflected in this project members of
each of the five teams spoke about their
potential ideas for the project Jessica
Henson wants the memorial to be
something that lives on for Generations
think how this becomes a place in the
future a place of healing a place of
coming together a place to look forward
together over the next four months the
five semi-finalist teams will develop
their proposals which will be unveiled
this summer and the finalists will be
sent to the County Commission to build
the permanent Memorial here behind me
reporting on the Las Vegas Strip for 8
news now I'm Brian will